can we all dress like we're a part of a
biker gang together I want to do a photo
show you're the closest one to it I know
I just tried a new look just a leather
jacket yeah that's what I'm already
starting I didn't know all right Harley
gave me a leather jacket 3 2 1 action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
we talked about what are you saying Joe
I hope the editor put the beginning part
in so they know what the hell we just
talked about but um yeah I want to do a
themed photo shoot with you guys where
we're like a biker gang
nice what inspired that this outfit so
just write assassins like look I saw
your post yes thank you
yeah I got a couple of more looks coming
out are you going through an assassin
phase yes because I just I just been
thinking like everyone's always talking
about like I can't get a job
or I'm not I'm making a lot on
unemployment more than I did before
whatever Ryan I was like but what about
the underworld the underworld is
struggling and no one's really no one
talks about it exactly you can't mug
anyone no one's going out in public
crime has gone down so they can't do
home invasions like yeah how can you
invade a home when there's people in
there yeah and and did you see the crime
statistics it dropped all the crime has
dropped
except for domestic violence because I
know like couples are fighting and [ __ ]
but then like I just felt bad because as
a former member of the underworld I said
what about all the people like no one's
thinking about them yeah you can't
really sell drugs as people don't even
have money yeah mmm so what are you
doing all that product but every
business is down yeah but we there is
help for that right so like if you if
you owned a donut shop you're gonna get
unemployment or the SBA whatever the
[ __ ] yeah but like let's say you own
a drug empire how much of the Care Act
is going to the Pablo Escobar's today
zero good friends and some would say
it's an essential need some do say I
mean like I know in San Francisco
they're giving [ __ ] homeless people
that are staying in hotel rooms tobacco
and alcohol because it's an essential
really yep you know the ritz-carlton
next to the Staples Center
that's a homeless housing place now what
the baller-ass knows it's Carl the
ritz-carlton because I want to take the
homeless off the street for the whole
corona stuff and then there's all these
real estate agents that are protesting
because they're pretty much saying like
how the [ __ ] am I supposed to sell these
houses if you got these people they'll
never get that out they're not gonna say
like that but I guess see it through
what this guy's trying to say he's
trying to use proper terminology but
he's pretty much saying I have two
million dollar penthouses how the [ __ ]
am I supposed to sell this [ __ ] if
people are wiping the ass all over the
carpet dude those rooms like $15,000 a
month yeah they gotta make a reality
show of this they're just putting a
homeless people inside like baller has
penthouses and just see what all these
people would do inside of it from bags
to riches yeah the world is upside down
right now let's put in you know so I was
trying to spread awareness for all the
people that might not know that there's
no jobs out there for assassins and
people that like me who are aspiring
hitmen so I just know getting any
inquiries to kill people know I just got
my contract that's why to celebrate I
wanted to share that post how does that
work um you you have to have a handler
you have to have a manager you have a
pen
basically and they do all the
negotiations for you and you you go out
and you don't want to break your own
deals cuz you know some people might be
like aw Joe he's mean you know like he
doesn't he doesn't really he's not nice
do you publicly announce your hits on
Instagram no no but diameter daddy like
a calling like you gotta take a picture
like my thing it's probably gonna be
like a coin right like I'll put like a
coin on there you flip the coin I'm just
starting I'm just starting you know like
maybe I'll come with another signature
here random coin or your own coin um
it'll probably be random like Oh penny
what are you my sander yeah something
like that because I'm gonna make a
choice exactly where they made his
custom coin because I'm trying to make
jamali of coins right now but that's a
whole different story
yeah but I thought it would be a pretty
fun idea to have like a theme every
month cuz I don't [ __ ] post on
Instagram at all
all and I was like we have all this time
man like might as well just doing some
creative [ __ ] that's what we're doing -
like with big mood we had our themes
we're like one of them was like really
formal the one where I wore my wedding
dress me Mickey world and then another
shoot was like a spa spa day
[ __ ] theme where we just had like
towels in her hair and face medicine
[ __ ] it's really fun doing theme I
should do a spa thing too I wanted to do
one of those uh were like back in the
day when in high school they look like
the photobooth stores especially a lot
of Mexican come to my school they had
all those so for big mood we were
actually literally planning on going to
one of those photo shoot studios and
then being like all Chola and [ __ ] or
like really like ninety like early 2000
but then this whole thing happened and
then they closed the foot of the photo
studio down so we had to cancel our
appointment do not have special business
we're about to go I know where there is
one there's one in k-town like the mall
photo ones there's one right here - so
have those yeah they happen yeah what
are you gonna I wanna get a photo
were you gonna cover your eyebrows kind
of like how how how is it the the people
when they cover their eyebrows but
you're gonna cover your eyebrows and
then you're gonna draw fake eyebrows
above your eyebrows do the Sharpie joke
ya know like for those like the real
people that did that they actually pluck
their eyebrows off oh I know you did
yeah yeah yeah I think you don't want to
shave your own eyebrows it probably just
one more round
no like those are the people that cover
their eyebrows right okay yeah sure yeah
like that Ora Ora geisha hmm
do this yeah you should do today they
cover their buck they paint over their
[ __ ] whole thing with white and then
they draw it what is up with the they
draw eyebrow up here maybe answer the
tongue got it baby you know why the the
geishas have like the
eyebrows up here that are the size of
like a thumb you know that was my only
standard back then dude why it was like
on there for your attention
you're like wow you're really high up
it's a conversation starter
without needing to do that an entire
surprise yeah black teeth was popular
black teeth was a hat they would get
charcoal and then black out their teeth
[ __ ] white skin so white that you
could be a bounce board charcoal
actually like you know how they have
those whitening like two thingies that
has charcoal in it so then back then
they wanted to make a black but it was
actually making their teeth whiter oh by
putting chuckle yeah I have the talk but
I don't use it as often as you could
tell but it works like if you use it
like I say like a weak Street your teeth
are super low yeah but then I really
really really really bad for your teeth
because it's actually like rubbing off
the really I want to have wooden teeth
what George Washington ending characters
have wooden teeth enough now and in
shows and movies normally Alex got sick
I don't know I can't recall that
specific shows or characters that owners
like you think and you can eat ice cream
all you want to bite into things and not
feel a damn you could do it Keith sounds
like it it might work but it's the wood
grain what I mean what grain is really
in right now yeah but what if we will
get soft mole do you this for my well
what if you smoke a cigarette you light
your teeth on fire burning well maybe
I'll get an enamel covering for the wood
wood grain veneers [ __ ] fair enough
how the people are getting veneers now
I'm about it what about this I supposed
to go get veneers and then the whole um
I was thinking about it but I heard
horror stories about it
see anywhere you would need it I need it
really
wait what's up veneer it's like this
plastic fake no know if it's porcelain
they have different types of
metallization whatever it's a weird
material you put on and then it makes
your like your teeth look [ __ ]
perfect like perfect perfect like the
way it's a yeah but it looks so like
like [ __ ] Chiclets
like it looks too
perfectly the bad ones the bad ones you
could go to things so every single actor
they you see auntie you have veneers huh
is it like you wake up in the morning
and put it on like that yeah they're
glued they don't come out for like 20
years if you get good ones yeah
somewhere like five ten years but the
good ones come let me see you got [ __ ]
up teeth my weirdness your teeth is
better than mine and I think mine's
perfect my own personal veneers fix that
after you the surgery on it to remove
that mm that one has to be fixed but
that's it on there well I do but I'm not
wearing them now no I mean like the
veneers oh yeah yeah no there's some my
teeth yeah a lot that I see they have
good teeth right and then I guess it's
not like picture perfect enough so they
put that on and then it now looks I
guess picture perfect but so picture
perfect it throws off the rest of it so
people are done because you go when you
go you're gonna choose like the shades
and stuff yeah so they are like hey this
is what looks natural and this is the
color shade that looks natural right and
then they're like it's too yellow but
everyone's like no I want I want a super
straight word could you know like this
cuz like I had grinded my teeth down to
be like super not not on purpose this
was like obviously something I didn't
want to do but my teeth are grinded down
to be completely flat at the bottom
which looks unnatural how did you do
that looks my eyes are teeth in her
sleep like I literally wake up in the
middle of the night and she's like yeah
but I have to wear like a mouth guard
yeah okay types of veneers like the ones
I was gonna get they literally shave
your teeth down yeah to fit them in yeah
I've heard I was thinking about getting
it because uh both my friends what's all
this [ __ ] has I've chipped teeth it's
pretty teeth too but you can't even tell
it's chip I was thinking about doing it
for a while and then uh yeah and then
I'll see my character though how's that
yeah I never noticed until you told me
like right now that
looking at it because I just like Joe
said I didn't notice until you said the
Lloyd Christmas look I do think people
analyze themselves too much doing by her
I heard horror stories where like cousin
to make it fit they have to like grind
down your teeth and then where it's the
point where they they would cut all the
teeth into like spikes yeah so they
maybe if you look at like your teeth
right now they'll they'll shave enough
room so the teeth can go over it and
where they glue it on so it's it's
literally they'll be like the same size
or whatever like you get a literally
choose if you want bigger frames you do
whatever but they're there they just
like this light that cures the the glue
they stick them on you can't pull them
off some some people had issues when
they got hit or stuff that like any
tooth that would fall off but it's
pretty cool like they literally take
part of the sheet on your tooth you know
what I do wish that have veneers for for
the pizookie that I ordered on postmates
see oh really yeah
you ordered a pizookie on postmates yeah
so yesterday we were just going through
the post mates because you know these
these were super quarantine so we're
ordering fluid a little bit more and on
the weekend we like to go all out so
we'll order like food and the desert and
what do we miss and I miss pizookie I
don't know what pizookie is it's like
this half melted cookie and ice cream
and you put it on top and what's cool is
they did a really good job of separating
the two so the cookie arrived warm and
the ice cream arrived cold look did it
cook cuz you know Kazuki's come in like
their pen little pen yet like a imagine
like you know like a like a playa high
oil but smaller always a big in that pie
for that they lifted it out their
original skillet thing and then they put
it into them because you're fit I ate
too fast to notice that one but if you
guys are anything anyone like me you
probably start thinking about what to
eat for dinner while you're eating lunch
I love food that's why I love using
pulse mates they deliver food from every
restaurant I can think of right to my
door
but post mates doesn't just deliver
burgers and sushi they also got bouzouki
they actually make life easier with
grocery delivery and whatever I can
think of delivery to convenience stores
clothing stores you name it batteries
batteries no more trips to the store
no more late-night fast food runs I
don't even have to worry about where to
grab my lunch anymore
just download post mates on iOS or
Android find her favorites and get
anything you want delivered within the
hour okay so for a limited time post
mates is giving our listeners $100 of
free delivery credit for your first 7
days to start your free deliveries
download the app and use the code off
the record
that's called off the record for $100 of
free delivery credit with no minimum
purchase for your first 7 days when you
download the post meats app anything you
need anytime you need that post made it
if you guys could change something about
your physical self what would it be a
laundry list of things laundry is there
do you prioritize is there what stuff to
your liking adds it sits it bothers me
but I can live without well I mean right
now I'm working on the thing that I
prioritize which is my teeth because um
yeah like I've had braces so many times
and I'm just like tired of it constantly
cuz then I'll break I'll break my my
retainer and then I won't wear it for
like years and then my teeth end up
shifting again so is it looking or is it
like uncomfortable in your mouth it's a
little bit of both because it's mainly a
look thing cuz you know every time I
take photos always smile and so like for
me my my smile is important my teeth are
important and numbers the thought about
changing that way really that's true
instead of smiling frowning frowning for
everything did you ever smile with your
mouth closed
yeah and I don't like it really nice it
just feels like like I don't want to
smile you know like that's so natural to
me sometimes I will smile like that in
some photos but for the most part I just
feels unnatural and like I just always
have to show my teeth when I was a kid I
was to smile and I would push my tongue
try to push my tongue through the cracks
of the teeth
why was there a reason or for fun I
thought they've made it my smile even
smile your mic not only is my teeth
smiling but my tongue is trying to wait
what's Murray Dobbs
reflection you to the reason they say
push your tongue against your teeth this
because it relaxes your face are they
but you're going you're stressing even
more you're like tackle when you tell
them to flex yeah but then the the
uncomfortable part though is because
when my teeth shift sometimes like it
will catch my my my lips like the inside
of my lip and sometimes I'll bite it
oh so I'm like what the [ __ ] and then
I'll end up getting canker sores because
like I'm biting the inside of my oh yeah
yeah yeah your ma your mouth giving you
all kinds of struggles I could smile
like that too when I was a kid I just
pressed my lips against us to each other
like really tight like this what's wrong
with you guys smile and then I'm like
hmm like I never learned how to smile
why did you smile even smile now I used
to hate try my teeth yeah back to you
thing like my I had a tooth that goes
behind its cover that one too yeah we
know what I used to cuz I wanted a big
jaw and always thought y'all for well
back then I just was self-conscious a
lot of things right yeah yeah when did
you start wanting a jaw it's not when
did you start wanting it like it's not a
thing a kid wants when he grows up just
knew where my mouth was open like that
yeah I look better so would always walk
around like that right so with your
mouth okay like a mouth breather closed
no no that oh that one technique right
so you can make your face like how that
relaxed like this my cheeks like this
and I used to put my tongue over my
teeth I literally would walk around like
that like a hundred bite nobody didn't
look like that alright let me see
okay so tell me Sean so this is what you
want to look like before and then what
do you look like without doing it this
way now I know yeah that was stupid
right so back then you wanted to look
like a bulldog yeah but even with lips
right uh and then uh
is stupid I always wonder when I look at
like pictures with like like kids
closing in the pictures you do parents
ever teach their kids how to smile in
the picture cuz I feel like a lot of
times you look at like family photos the
kid always goes yeah but you know what
happens cuz I see that sometimes with
Isaac like I like taking photos of him
you coach him well yeah so cool but what
ends up happening is that I'll be like
okay baby smile and then so he's like
smiling and like the first photo that
I'll take is like really natural
whatever but then if I take a little too
long or I'm taking too many guys get
tired with this yeah I like the entire
face starts getting tired with like does
like taking pictures I like with fans
and stuff no you guys it's like crazy
hours on end just looking how hard that
was by the end of the meeting greed you
just kind of have to remember to be like
to do the smize too cuz during those
events where it's like just forever like
this like it's been like it's not
natural then I end up looking like this
like like the kid photo you're like do
you overcompensate so then you're just
like why bar just stinks no I just got a
whiff or something no I would wear some
[ __ ] in this office for like the past
like a couple months where I'm like what
the [ __ ] is I've asked him a couple
times like I'm like baby did you fart it
might be trash oh yeah last time yeah
but it was the food that you didn't eat
and kept blaming me for farting I didn't
blame you oh that requiring did you I
remember being a kid and looking at the
photos and then going why the [ __ ] did I
look like that and I think it's mainly
because my mom telling me to take
pictures and I didn't want to take yeah
so you're just [ __ ] forcing it yeah
cuz I'm already like like I'm like let's
say I'm like I already played piano at
the talent show that I didn't really
want to do I came off stage wait wait
wait wait time to take a picture oh my
and it's all like another glass no
Millie ate it though like back then
right like are you wanted to dress like
a [ __ ] man and I'm over here being
like 5 years old and they put me in a
little [ __ ] [ __ ] outfit
they always find those wack is [ __ ] dude
I had some short ass shorts with some
socks up to my [ __ ] knees they're
like a bowtie and like I look like a
human doll and [ __ ] and I'm standing
there like why can't I just be in a suit
like all the other man like why the [ __ ]
do I have to look like this dude more
parents are the worst with dressing like
you that's what I'm saying it's like wow
what's a dress in America but yeah I got
to show you this guy you guys she has
his picture and later of how my mom's to
dress me and they just looks ridiculous
I don't know how my mom found this shirt
it was a shirt with [ __ ] lace on the
[ __ ] collar dude yeah it was like a
lace on a damn collar with a bowtie that
was way too damn big like a clown and I
had suspenders and I was like what the
[ __ ] may be Halloween yeah what are you
dressed well my dad on the music school
so we would I would do a lot of
performances and yeah I would do a lot
of things and in like I liked I liked
performing by the end of the day I'm
always like the clothes would be all
[ __ ] up right maybe they're trying to
make you look like Prince already I
always wanted a suit though but when
they got me a suit I [ __ ] wore that
[ __ ] like double-oh-seven
it's like now I'm like an adult you know
so cute that reminds me of Isaac when we
finally got him a suit you like you just
never wanted to take it off yeah she was
so cool I mean cuz when you're a kid you
just want to do what the adults are
doing you don't want to look like a doll
I hated it as a kid only because kid
suits are always too big for them you
know what I mean no one gets a tailor
for because you and then especially like
parents you always want to buy things
that you can grow into and I'm like what
am I gonna grow into the suit and by the
time you do you're not wearing a suit
anywhere anymore
driven by time you do need to wear it
again you're it's too [ __ ] small
exactly [ __ ] missed the [ __ ]
crying time to wear this [ __ ] but you
know what the worst part is the neck
part man oh that was horrible I don't
know it's it's it's like a guy's high
heel like when it's like becoming a man
right is like you have to put the neck
part on and then you get a real clip-on
tie and you put that on top real
my right you do look sharpest [ __ ]
though when the whole being is there
yeah it looks really like you guys like
when Sue's now I do actually look it
makes you feel yeah I don't feel like a
scoundrel yeah but when I was a kid
though the neck part got me man I cuz I
wouldn't I hated that yeah I was way too
tight
[Music]
[Music]